what is austrian economics what is
kenzian economic what how do you compare
the two
what should people know some interest
what are
interesting defining characteristics to
you about these schools yeah
so austrian economics the way that i
said austrian economics is economics
it's um it we call it australian
economics because economics has been
hijacked by
a bunch of frauds really people who are
wrong
well it's much worse than wrong by
people who are just essentially
propagandists for inflation right um so
it's like your opinion man
all right
yeah well that's also like your opinion
man yeah but
that's true well i also talked to paul
krugman on this podcast so he's uh
the o speaks enough but he is uh he's
one of the people that is perhaps most
harshly criticized
by folks
in
austrian economics perspective and vice
versa which is a fascinating intention
yeah he's um he's done a great job as an
actor who plays an economist on tv and
the internet
so anyway uh now tell me what you really
think no but so the basics of what is
austrian economics what is the what
perspective does it take in the world
yeah so i mean austrian economics really
is
uh the continuation of a tradition that
it goes back to the ancient greeks of
studying economics historically it's
really just economics and that has
evolved over time and the
um
the establishment of the austrian school
per se came in 1871 150 years ago
when carl menger the father of the
school wrote a book called principles of
economics
and essentially invented marginal
analysis which is a big deal in
economics marginal analysis is the idea
that in economics individuals carry out
decisions at the margin that it's
um when you when you make choice you're
not making it for instance if you're
making a choice between uh what should i
spend my money on you're not making a
choice whether it is
um this thing is
object a or b which one is more valuable
for me in general which one is more
valuable for me for the rest of my life
you're choosing about the next unit
right now
at this point at this stage and if you
analyze economic decision making at the
margin it makes a lot more sense and you
can understand why people decide and
make the decisions that they do
whereas if you
don't apply marginal analysis things
don't make sense
the key thing that marginal analysis
helps us solve is what is called the
water diamond paradox
so you will die without water we all
need water and yet water is dirt cheap
whereas diamonds are
extremely superfluous nobody needs them
nobody's going to live or die because
they have a diamond and yet they're
extremely expensive so why is it that as
human beings we pay
maybe say a dollar a liter
for water whereas we pay thousands of
dollars for a few grams of diamonds
why is this the case do we value water
less than diamond
the answer is no but at the margin
where we are right now you live in a
place where water is very abundant
because cities are only built in places
where water is abundant
and
you're only making a choice about the
next unit of water and so water is
extremely abundant and
you're choosing about whether to spend
the next
unit of money on water the valuation
that you give to water given that you
have a lot of water at home
and then you live in a place that has
abundant water
is pretty low to the marginal unit
but it's very high for water overall so
if i asked you
how much would you spend for
water in general you know how much would
you uh pay for water for all of your
life it would be a lot higher than
diamonds if i told you you can only have
water or diamonds for the rest of your
life you choose water obviously
but you nobody's ever had to make that
choice you only make your choices at the
margin
so at the margin where we are modern
civilization we have an abundance of
water that's why we have civilization
and diamonds are very rare and scarce
and
people are only buying you know you buy
your first diamond when you're gonna get
married and you give it to your wife and
that's it's gonna be the first few
grams of diamond that she's ever gonna
giving my wife water
smart move you should definitely give
her bitcoin instead of diamonds i tell
my wife i occasionally remind her what
uh what we how many bitcoin we could
have had if i bought her bitcoin with
the price of the diamond what's the
downside of by the way diamonds for
from the analysis of like gold and so on
ah that's a great question
um arguably diamonds are scam
[Laughter]
because they became popular as a thing
in marriage
after gold was banned after gold
ownership was banned in the us in the
1930s and in many places around the
world so before that you'd give gold and
the reason you'd give gold in a dowry in
uh wedding
is because you know it wasn't just that
it's pretty and shiny it's because it's
money and so um you know if you die or
your wife can take the gold and she can
live off of it um it's it's a
demonstration that you're giving her
something valuable
and that's because nobody can make a lot
more gold that has the high stock to
flow ratio but then they banned gold
ownership where they allowed people to
only own very tiny quantities of gold
and that's when the diamond industry
stepped in and marketed diamonds as
the thing that you need to give but the
problem with it is of course that
diamonds aren't uh like gold they're not
very hard to
make more of and the reason we have uh
scarcity in diamonds is really
artificial there's a there's effectively
a monopoly of diamond producers they
restrict the supply
and um it's a pretty dirty business and
the way that they do it is you know all
the um all of the talk about um
blood diamonds is a way for them to
ensure their monopoly so
um
if you're part of the monopoly of
diamond producers then doesn't matter
how many people get killed producing
your diamonds if you're out of the
monopoly then human rights organizations
descend on you
and call for shutting you down for
selling blood diamonds and they're also
restricting the production of artificial
dimes this is the other thing you can
make artificial diamond you can't make
artificial gold
so they restrict the production of
artificial diamond and they try and
insist that you know you shouldn't take
artificial diamonds but
they're indistinguishable from real
diamonds so it's an artificial scarcity
and i think there's going to come a
point at some point that this monopoly
is going to break and a lot of people
are going to be left with uh
essentially uh
highly devalued
jewelry i'm going to take this segment
of the podcast when i'm getting married
i'm gonna send it and then uh instead
you're you're getting
uh water or bitcoin yes and water and
bitcoin is all you need so so marginal
analysis guessing and the margin
is the thing that allows you to most
accurately capture human nature the
actual day-to-day decisions that we
humans make
yeah that's really revolutionized
economics so 1870 and that's um that was
mangers uh work
and then um he had a student
agent bombard who developed
capital theory and then he had a student
ludwig von mises who
is arguably the most important economist
ever and he developed a theory of money
and
he wrote a book in 1912 called the
theory of money and credits
and then in the 40s he wrote human
action which is
a big treatise on economics and i think
this is um this is the correct tradition
of economics and before
world war one this was just known as
economics and then
um after what happened in world war one
and i discussed this in detail in the
fiat standard is that the bank of
england essentially went off gold
and tried to pass off their own credit
as being as good as gold
in order to finance the war
and incidentally here um this is part of
the history that is not discussed often
you know this is presented as an
innovation
um later on
they needed essentially a propaganda
school that would justify what they did
and uh later on it's presented as oh hey
we realized that gold was not good and
now look we've built this thing
that is better than gold where now the
government can just print money whenever
it wants and now
um gold money is not an issue anymore
which is extremely idiotic because the
whole point of money is that it's not
easy to make if it's easy to make it's
not money anymore it's just destroying
the entire
function of money and we've seen that
happen extensively in the 20th century
after countries went off the gold
standard
so essentially keynesian economics is
just inflation apologia it's just
propaganda to justify inflationism and
it's
profoundly nonsensical it's built on the
idea that if you just make more money
you can stimulate economic production
and of course this is very self-serving
to the central banks and to the banks
and to the governments who promote this
nonsense
and this is also very pervasive if
you've had the misfortune of studying at
a university over the last century you
were taught keynesian garbage economics
you were taught that
if if there's a problem in the economy
the way to fix it is that the government
prints money the government lowers the
interest rate and then
that
leads to more economic production which
is completely nonsensical so
so you're again for the listener you're
using strong words and i'll push back
just to uh find
uh to please the devil's advocate to
hopefully one day arrive at the truth
so
just because it's in the interest of the
central banks and the government
uh the interests and the models of
kenzian economics and the government are
aligned doesn't mean they're wrong
so let's let's give them a chance
so
the conventional wisdom
perhaps economics wisdom is that
inflation is good
uh in moderation as it encourages
spending but too much is bad because
you know it completely devalues destroys
people's savings so a little bit of
inflation is good to stimulate spending
um
and
i mean i suppose this is one of the
things that's supported by uh kenzie in
economics
wow this is basically the whole point of
keynesian economics is to try and find
uh an endless array of explanations to
explain why inflation is a good thing
well it could the chicken in the egg so
that's that's the cynical take yeah this
is a propaganda machine to sell the
government's narrative the less cynical
take is this a bunch of economists who
are telling who um
who figured out this thing and it
happens to be good for banks and
governments just because it's good for
them doesn't mean and it justifies the
existence of government and
uh your basic
i don't think it's your basic assumption
but a foundational principle of your
thought is that a lot of government is
not a good thing your first gut instinct
government bad like i mentioned i lived
next door to michael malus who probably
beats you on the intensity
and how quickly he says government bad
so
so but there you know there's a
potential argument for government good
go some government is good maybe a lot
of government is good maybe we need a
lot of centralized management
for resource allocation and so on
because we humans specialize we're too
busy and so on so is an argument for
that
uh that exists uh you probably disagree
with any possible argument in that side
but anyway so why is that idea yeah of
kensington economics wrong i'm gonna
focus for this on the uh
money idea the idea that a little bit of
inflation is good um
the idea here i mean the criticism
is that without inflation people
wouldn't spend and then the economy
would come to a grinding halt
and that's nonsensical because people
spend not because they want to keep this
magical monster called the economy going
people spend because they need to
consume because you know that's how we
live that's how we survive you need to
eat you need shelter you need clothes to
keep you warm
and as technology advances the
capabilities of the things that we can
do with our
um
with our time increases and so we want
to buy more things so people buy things
because people want to consume there's a
limitless desire to consume you know
that there's no
there's no um shortage of reasons for
people to consume whether it's food or
ferraris or
private jets people just always want to
buy more can i interrupt just really
quick what about the fear about the
uncertainty of the future where they
might want to they might want to
uh
buy things but they're really afraid
because it seems like there's a lot like
a pandemic going on or whatever it is
that's good so so fear of uncertainty is
yeah but can you have too much fear
here's the thing what i was saying is i
was making the point that
we don't need to be motivated to consume
like we have the insatiable desire to
consume everybody would like to have
more of all kinds of things everybody
would like to have a bigger house well
not everybody some people have a big
enough house but everybody would like a
house everybody would like a car jet
all kinds of things you know electronics
machines
so
we don't need a desire to consume but of
course the limit on how much we consume
is
opportunity cost
why don't you buy a ferrari well because
that's really expensive and it would
mean that you know well maybe you do
have a ferrari but i mean most people
don't buy a ferrari because
it's too expensive they don't they can't
afford it they'd have to work too hard
to get it
um and if they do get it it might mean
that you know they can't afford their
house anymore so we have to economize
that's a good thing and we have to also
think of the future
and so humans consume that we don't need
more motivation to consume we have to
deal with the economic reality of the
things that limit us from consuming more
so um
what keynesians present is that when
there is a problem in the economy like
there was after world war one
the problem is always
a cause
caused by the inflation
and what the keynesian hucksters do is
that they look at the inflation
at the consequences of inflation and
blame it on people not spending enough
when people are doing the rational thing
you know the money is
um the so there was inflation caused the
uh
an unsustainable boom it caused the
recession and now a lot of people lost
their jobs and they don't have enough
money to go out and spend um frivolously
so they save for the future the future
is uncertain that's a good thing you
know that's how you fix things um you
begin the recovery by
well you know you lost some wealth so
you spend less like if you you know if
your business goes bust if you lose your
job
it's natural and smart that you stop
spending money on the frivolous thing
that you used to spend
and you save it for the future you
invest in something else you get a new
job and then once you've recovered you
start spending more this is this is very
sane and very good and it's the way to
recovery
but essentially the keynesians have used
this as a justification for more
inflation
because inflation is an addiction once
the government gets down the path of
spending money to solve its problems
then
every problem looks like it can be
solved by more inflation and so
this is where keynesian economics comes
in and of course the keynesian economics
is based on the work of keynes which
came in the 1930s
and this is the key point like um it's
portrayed in the textbook as if it's
just
this this scientific breakthrough that
you know somebody in the 1930s this
genius came about and realized that oh
we don't actually need gold we don't
need hard money we can actually just
print all the money
and in reality of course it was just the
very thin flimsy idiotic justification
for what governments were already doing
for 20 years they'd already gone off the
gold standard
and they'd gone through 20 years in
which they were lying to their
population telling their population
we're still on a gold standard but you
know
there are problems caused by various
random things but don't worry we're
going to be going back on the gold
standard 20 years later after they went
off the gold standard they come up with
this
justification for why oh actually the
gold standard was bad and and this is
really pernicious thing about it is the
problems that were caused by us going
off the gold standard we're
caused by the gold standard and we're
going to fix them by going off the gold
standard even more just because
government is lying and it's shady and
it does these kinds of things doesn't
mean kensington economics is wrong so
just because i wanted to separate a few
things you said uh it could very well be
very wrong
and they could indeed be hucksters all
of these colorful such colorful language
uh i i love you deeply for this this
this is fun yeah but i mean you know
it's not like somebody like krugman
doesn't use this kind of language when
discussing austrians it's just that when
actors like him use it it's presented as
if it is um legitimate because he's you
know he's part of the major shows
[Laughter]
so the case they make and the criticism
uh kenzians make of austrian economics
in the case they make for kensington
economics is it's based on empirical
evidence
so
uh
austrian economists are pie in the sky
theorists about
like how human nature works and it's
just all theory uh and just like you
said kenzie and economics kind of sell
it as a science data-driven science and
so um
where's the data bro
on the on the uh so one way of saying it
is um
how do you know if we get rid of
inflation
how do you know if we get rid of central
banks if we push towards that direction
we will have a better world
a better functioning economy better
functioning markets better functioning
society
this is
another inaccurate way in which they
present
the economics they present as if it's
just theory and the data doesn't matter
but that's not the case
what the austrians say is that without
guiding theory data is mute data is dumb
data can't say anything so
theory first and then uh you have to
have models
to provide context for interpretation of
exactly data and it's a sign of just how
little self-awareness they have that
they think
that they're just being led by the data
when they're
being led by keynes's moronic theories
and it's
they use the data to justify those
theories and to stick by them
and in fact they are the ones whose
theories cannot be refuted because it's
just uh it's just government-mandated
religion so according to keynes's
nonsense
um you know
so the way that the whole thing is
the way that they justify the
inflationism is this and i'm just using
this to give an example of what you're
talking about in terms of theory the way
they justify the inflationism to tie it
back to the original point they just
all right we need money to spend and
then the level of spending in the
economy is what determines the state of
the economy and i have taught
macroeconomics at university level for a
while so i know this
i know keynesian nonsense better than
most keynesians know austrians if not
all of them i i guarantee you and so
the way they see it is the level of
spending in the economy is what
determines the state of the economy
there's a level of output and there's a
level of spending so there's like the
factories on the one side that are
churning out goods and those goods have
a certain quantity and value market
value
it's completely nonsensical of course
because
um how can the value of the goods
produced be different from the value of
the spending but let's put that aside
for a sentence for a second
so the amount of spending that happens
in the economy determines the state of
the economy if the value of the
production which they call y
is higher than the aggregate expenditure
so this is the production and the
aggregate expenditure is lower then we
don't have enough spending to buy all
the goods and then that causes a
recession the factories start laying off
workers and then the laid off workers
start spending less and then that leads
to aggregate expenditure dropping even
further and so it's a vicious cycle
where the economy gets into recession
and the only way out is for keynes's
bankster buddies and government buddies
to print a lot of money to give to
themselves
and then um that will that's one
interpreter so but to uh so to print
more money to increase the expenditure
that to match the match the level of
sounds pretty good to me i'm sold
all right but you even though you're
saying huckster so yes i just you know
like the way i i love you very much but
like uh just for people who are
listening i think it's i love the way
you talk and it's great and keep doing
it but just for context
um
like i don't know anything that involves
human nature
deserves this level of certainty i at
least my position
is that we don't know what the hell
we're doing on basically anything and
perhaps but i mean like there's a lot
like certainty can get us in trouble
it's my worry i don't know much about
economics i don't even know you know
financial systems monetary systems
um
but i just seen us get in trouble with
human psychology certainty certainty of
ideologies in general you mentioned
marxism and so on i came from the soviet
union there's a lot of people that are
very certain throughout the history of
the 20th century that communism
is the utopia that humanity should
strive for so i'm i'm nervous around
certain i could be wrong but you know
you you asked me for my opinion yes yes
sorry so it's that little bit of a
caveat so to go back to the idea then on
the other hand you have the level of if
the you know the other situation is when
the level of spending is higher than the
amount of aggregate output yes in that
situation you have too much spending so
therefore what ends up happening is
inflation
so according to the keynesian worldview
this is really important because this is
a way that i'm going to get to your
point about empirical data and to show
you why
they're
not correct
yeah they're not correct about what they
say about empirical data so then what
this means is that there's a level of
output and there's a level of aggregate
expenditure the aggregate expenditure
can either be higher or lower than the
output or equal to it
if it's higher we get inflation if it's
lower we get
recessions okay
so
is there any universe in this model is
there any
potential universe in which you can have
both inflation and a recession
according to the keynesian model you
can't
right because aggregate expenditure
cannot be both higher and lower than
output
so therefore if you're truly being an
empirical uh person if you were looking
at evidence and trying to be
and like trying to analyze data you'd
look at this and say
one example you know one you just need
one example of high inflation and high
unemployment to refute this entire model
right
and of course the world is full of
examples of high inflation and high
unemployment and that's what happened in
the 19 and of course you know they
ignored it and when it happens in poor
countries because you know poor
countries don't really matter but then
in the 1970s that happened in the us and
in the western economies in the most
advanced industrial economies so
historically before then you had all
these keynesian
central bankers
talking about this model and saying you
know well aggregate expenditures too low
now and that's why we have unemployment
so we need to print more money and then
they print more money inflation goes up
but also unemployment goes up
because this model is broken that's not
how the world works that's not the level
of aggregate spending in the economy is
not a lever with which you can control
inflation and unemployment so what would
a scientist do what would a non-huckster
do in this case
admit the theories wrong and find
another way to reformulate it
have the keynesians done that no still
the same garbage in the textbook that is
being taught until today so is it
possible to have a non-kenzia motto or
one that still supports moderate amount
of inflation is good for the economy i
mean since the 1970s since this has
happened yeah this is what um
basically most uh
fiat economists as i like to call them
essentially anybody at a university
financed by governments which is
financed by central banks which is fine
but we'll talk about that yes the effect
of
fiat
money on our life as you write about in
your book
uh fiat standard one of them is
education i'm sure we'll disagree there
too um i'm not smart enough to disagree
but i'll disagree anyway so yeah so a
whole bunch of other models came up but
basically it's i mean it's it's such an
example of motivated reasoning like
anybody who's got a familiarity with the
scientific method or who's got an
engineering background who comes into
economics immediately has a lot of red
flags and
i remember when i used to teach
macroeconomics i used to teach you know
introductory macroeconomics and it's a
course that would be taken by econ
majors as well as engineers a lot of
engineers would take it as an elective
and every time i'd explained and i would
just teach you know the keynesian basic
stuff and every time i'd explain it
there's always that smart engineering
kid who just looks at me
and says sir this doesn't make any sense
because this and this and that i'm
always like you get it exactly you're
correct because if you have any kind of
shred of scientific thinking you see
that this is all motivated reasoning
like the answer is government needs to
print money
and here's a whole bunch of models
brought up by people for why government
printing money is good and
the reason they're coming up to this
conclusion is that you only get funded
if you come up with this conclusion if
you come up with a conclusion that we
need to
shut down the central bank you don't get
funded by the central bank you don't get
published in the journals you don't get
a job at the prestigious universities
you don't get quoted by fiat
publications like the new york times and
cnn they don't invite you on as an
expert well that's a fundamental flaw
with a lot of institutions we have today
a human and throughout human history let
me zoom out for just a second to the big
question what is economics
in general what's the goal you said
there's a bunch of models is any any
economist basically trying to throw a
bunch of models about human behavior on
the table and try to generalize it to
the global scale
so both dance between micro and macro
somehow in order to determine public
policy and ex explain the past predict
the future
prescribe
policies that can control the future
those kinds of things that's the big
basic ridiculous question of what is
economics
economics is the study the way the
austrians define it is the study of how
humans make choices under the condition
of scarcity we begin with the starting
point of economics as the fact that
scarcity exists
and
why does scarcity exist well because
it's easier to want things than it is to
make them it's much easier to want a
ferrari than it is to make one
and so um
because it's you know we have once and
we have limited means to meet those
wants we need to economize it's a
permanent
it's a permanent marker of the human
condition we are always economizing at
all times
and so
how people make those decisions under
the conditions of scarcity
is what economists study
so to go back to your point on
empiricism in austrian school
so it isn't that the austrians don't
believe in data
on the contrary it's that
theory has to inform data and in fact if
you think about it as the example of the
um stagflation of the 1970 shows
um
if you have stagflation that just
completely refutes the keynesian model
the austrian way of thinking which is
think from first principles understand
how the world actually works think about
how humans act and understand that
economics is really all about human
action so it's not about
aggregates of goods this is really the
key distinction in terms of methodology
and for the keynesians
it's physics envy they look at the
market economy they could individuals in
the market economy
and they think that they can understand
the market economy by looking at
aggregates this is really the key point
of what i think makes
the
certain branch of economics
pseudoscientific is the introduction of
aggregates when you when you introduce
those aggregates you know how much
production takes place how many people
are unemployed um the percentage of the
inflation rate and then you think that
you can establish scientific
relationship between those aggregates
it's purely physics envy you you know in
physics
for instance or in chemistry you put
let's say a container with contains uh a
gas and you have the uh ideal gas law pv
equals the nrt calculate the pressure
calculate the volume
and then uh and and then the temperature
you can you can if you have the pressure
and volume you can calculate the
temperature because you have the um n
constants
so there's a
clear relationship that has been
demonstrated in a laboratory and that
can you know we can do it right now we
can measure it and we can see it and it
continues to hold and all it takes is
one scientist to show that this
relationship does not hold to do an
experiment that shows this does not hold
and it stops being a law of
chemistry um then it's and it's broken
where
whereas in
economics what they've done is they've
copied the superficial shape of this
without any of the scientific rigor that
was used to build it there's no
experiments you can't experiment on
economies we don't have the ability to
establish laws
and all the laws that we establish are
just models that get people published
and get them on the media to say
my model says we need to print more
money but it's never subject to actual
scientific scrutiny if it were they
would all be rejected in 15 minutes
because the world is full of examples
that contradict them was it possible to
do scientific scrutiny when it's human
nature when you can't when there's a
nearly infinite number of variables and
you can't control them it's a part so
what's the best thing you could possibly
do
you do thought experiments
but the problem with thought experiments
you know freud thinks everybody wants to
have sex with their mother
uh is the right problem with freud
i don't know maybe he's right well
obviously i'm joking on that front but
the
freud is probably another keynes
well no i i think there's power to the
thought experience just like einstein
you know a lot of general relativity
special relativity that that's a thought
experiment it originates in a thought
experiment now is it true
you know a nice thing about physics you
can't eventually have experimental
validation the the downside of economics
is you really can't have experimental
like definitive experimental scientific
rigor of validation of a theory so a
thought experiment is just a thought
experiment using your intuition
it's the power of reasoning together
against human nature and that's why
economics cannot make the claims that
physics can make so with physics you can
predict that if you get this gas at this
pressure at this volume the temperature
will be that much and you can make that
prediction and and test it a million
times and you'll always get the
precisely correct answer with economics
we can't make quantitative predictions
on twitter and even today you're very
certain about the statements you're
making
do you yeah but i don't make
quantitatively certain statements that's
the thing in economics we don't make
quantitative predictions we cannot do
that because we don't have experiments
but we can
understand how the world actually works
with humility this is really the key
difference that the keynesians think
they just want to copy the methods of
physics and then that's just you know
going to give them the certainty of the
results of physics which is like me
saying i'm just going to put a red um
blanket on my back and jump from the
fourth floor because i'm superman well
it's not the red blanket that's going to
make me superman it doesn't there's a
lot more to it so humility
manifests itself in economics as the
belief in a free market
meaning like i can't centralize i can't
do centralized control on this thing
we're going to uh
minimize the friction of the free
exchange of goods
so um austrian economics puts priority
in in the market
yes and you could you could you could
arrive at it through two paths the the
the more um
the more practical path which most
scientific minded people arrive at you
know i came from an engineering
background so i initially had this idea
that
what is lacking in economics is
mathematicization we need to have better
math models we need to get all those
tools from engineering apply them to
economics and then we'll be able to plan
the world economy and make it work
better and then you start actually
trying to solve problems you know to try
and actually calculate them and you
realize nobody can have that ability
because
the difference ultimately comes down to
the fact
we can't have experiments and the reason
we can't have experiments is that you
can experiment on particles of a gas you
can't experiment on human beings on
entire economies
and because
particles of a gas are just dumb matter
and so you know you you kick matter in a
certain way you can calculate exactly
how much is going to fly human beings
are much more complex they have a will
inside them and this is really
the this is the humility to understand
that you are a human being and other
people are also a human being just like
you and that
the the you know every person wakes up
every morning and they have a million
things in their mind a million things
they care about a million things they
want to do
and
you will never be able to make the
decisions for somebody else let alone
for millions of other people so this is
one path by which you arrive at the
conclusion that free markets are better
because you realize that all the people
that think that they can centrally plan
markets
can't actually do that
and that there's really
nothing scientific about them except
essentially the rituals they ape of the
scientific process
and the other path i think that iran may
survive at the austrian
perspective or the libertarian
perspective i should say
is um
simply the the the notion of individuals
as having their own inalienable right to
decide what they want to do with
themselves if you
i mean the only way that you can give
yourself the idea that um you get to be
planner
is ultimately you think you're better
than other people you think your choice
your judgment overrides mine
and i don't think that's a defensible
position i think
i'm in no position to want to force
anybody ever i will never want to force
anybody to do anything they don't want
the keynesian perspective the central
planning perspective is
unlike physics you know which is let's
force a bunch of particles to sit in the
lab so that we can study them
in economics you're forcing people to do
things you know that's stop these people
from doing this job because it's bad for
the economy and let's get them to do
that job let's force them to pay this
price let's tax them this much let's
prevent them from using gold as money
and force them to use our credit as
money so it has to rely on coercion
there's no central planning without
coercion and coercion is
a crime in my opinion there's no way
that it is justifiable morally or former
politics from an ethical perspective
uh your view is the i mean perhaps the
broadly speaking of the libertarian view
is uh coercion
is unethical
freedom is essential
what is what are the pros and cons of
government intervention in the economy
so can you steal man can you provide
pros you just kind of provided arguments
against
is there any arguments to be made for
government intervention for the role of
government in society speaking from a
political or from an economics
perspective what is a positive role of
government
that you could imagine you can speak to
i can repeat many other cases but i i
don't find any of them compelling for
the reason that i mentioned which is
that ultimately they all rely on putting
a gun to somebody's head and using the
threat of force so that's for me it can
never be justifiable whatever the ends
are
if the means are
violence and
the threat of violence then the ends
aren't justified everything that's good
governments will use as an excuse to
justify coercion so you know what do you
like you like motherhood and apple pie
well government needs to ensure that
motherhood works well and we need
government central planning of
birth we need regulations on birth for
instance we need regulations on uh how
people give birth we need to ban people
from giving birth in traditional ways
that have been tried for thousands of
years we need to force people to do
things in the modern scientific way well
so what about things like
that all of us use so infrastructure for
example or education
um
or well the economy too right uh
can you make a case
for the role of
some
large-scale centralized systems whether
it's government or not that do this kind
of management i guess perhaps you could
say there's the economies of scale
argument that some things must exist at
a very hard a very large scale and
therefore you would want
um you would want political
accountability of the people who manage
them this is kind of the argument that's
given for infrastructure monopolies you
know for instance roads or electricity
um
that let's say we live in a country we
need one power plant the bigger the
power plant the better off we will all
be
and there's a natural monopoly in the
power plant business so we're gonna have
to have one power plant and since it's
only one power plant then we can't just
let anybody
own it because then they're going to
make it too expensive so we need to have
the government own it so it can make it
too expensive and you don't find that
case compelling not at all i used to
believe in it i was pretty much a
keynesian when i first started my
graduate studies at colombia
and no i don't find that compelling at
all because i think all these examples
that they mention of natural monopolies
or economies of scale that can only fit
at a scale of government
um it's always
it's always you know government bans
people from opening power plants
and then there's only one power plant
and they need to be in charge of it
but in reality uh
no in reality the you know power plants
can exist at all kinds of manners of
scales of operation and yes of course
there are benefits to centralization in
power plants in particular because
there's efficiency in uh generation you
know one big uh power plant is more
efficient than 10 equivalent smaller
power plants but there's also
inefficiencies in centralization because
the more centralized and the bigger the
plant is the further away
a lot of the
population is going to be so you're
going to be losing a lot of the
electricity and transmission
and you believe the free market is best
in managing that dance that balance of
centralization
exactly and if we do end up in a
situation where there's one power plant
for an area
then i you know if the markets
ends up centralizing all of it into one
power plant i don't see that as a
problem um there are places you know
there's a small town with only one
barber shop is that a catastrophe no
because
they don't need two barbershops now if
that barber shop started to take
advantage of people started to charge
higher price well then that's just an
opportunity for others to step in and
put them in their place and that's the
same thing with power plants it's the
same thing with everything
um ultimately
i think the key thing is this
from the central planning perspective
they'll present you the problem as it is
and they'll tell you well this is bad so
the fix you know and and what we can do
is better so let's stop what's bad and
do what is better
two problems here usually the reason
that the thing is bad in the first place
is because it is a government monopoly
is because of government intervention
but the second thing is that this notion
that we could just pass a law and fix
what's wrong and make it better
is
it ignores the fundamental underlying
reality which is that what you're doing
is you're
offering only one way for this problem
to be solved and making all other
solutions practically illegal you're
taking taxpayer money you're putting
guns to people's heads to take their
money to use it to build say this one
solution for a power plant but you're
preventing the free market process from
providing us with other alternatives
well so you phrased it sort of from that
perspective but there in theory there is
a feedback accountability mechanism for
the solution that you propose and
enforce
by as you're saying placing a gun to
people's head
you're accountable for the uh for that
choice for the quality of that solution
by being voted out
if you if the solution is actually bad
so it's just a different selection
mechanism and
i think i personally believe it is a
selection mechanism that has worked in
the past it just often does not work
and nearly as well as a free market
and the question is are there domains
in which the free market gets itself
into trouble
so this
theoretical view is that
that's the point of a free market is it
doesn't if there's trouble
that's a signal and it will respond to
that signal and it will respond
appropriately to make you try to
maximize happiness the question is is
there a local optima that free markets
get stuck in and you need governments
to represent the broader scale of the
people you get well here
i think the fundamental problem here is
the idea that there is a feedback
mechanism when there is coercion in one
party when one party can employ coercion
and the other one cannot so in other
words i'm going to put a gun to your
head
i'm going to take your money and i'm
going to use it to buy more guns for me
to put against your head
but somehow you're going to put a paper
in a box and that's going to deactivate
my guns
well love requires a push and pull
there's a little bit of tension a little
spice in a relationship i think uh yeah
i mean uh hello gun to the headness and
good luck to anybody who's going to be
dating you if you think you're putting a
gun to people's head is comparable to a
relationship uh
all jokes but yes i i mean the people
don't often think of it as gun to the as
government and the military
as
gun to the head
um but that is sort of a libertarian
perspective because ultimately when you
you know turtles all the way down and at
the bottom there's guns
yeah so bottom if you don't want to pay
if you don't want to you know all right
i don't want to be part of your power
plant i want to get my own generator i
don't want to do it i don't want to pay
for it i go to jail you can't not pay
for it that's really the symmetry which
the market doesn't have which is why
in my opinion it's not as if you know
i'm being stubborn and stuck on the idea
that i want a market and that the
government can't work it's presented as
if you know we're choosing between two
different machines you know should we
use an apple or a pc and i'm just um
constantly choosing one of them and
saying that the other one can't work
it's not equivalent it's not two
machines we're comparing between a
machine and a gun to the head and we're
comparing between a situation in which
anybody anywhere is free to provide the
service or the good and anybody anywhere
is free to buy it from them or reject to
buy it from them so anyone can build a
power plant anyone can succeed that
anybody can fail at it anybody can build
it in a way that i can choose to take
part in or not take part in i can build
my own so we have a situation which 10
million people let's say they each can
freely choose
to provide the good or to buy the good
that cannot be considered an alternative
on an equal footing to a situation where
one person or one entity
gets to decide for everybody and those
who disagree go to jail so the problem
is
that
the alternative to governments is other
large successful entities that have
humans in them and human nature is such
that there's corruption manipulation and
so on i think free market
depends on the
honest
communication of information
as widely as possible so people can make
great rational decisions but
sort of my
fear is that like to propose is that in
general there's manipulation where
there's government where there's
companies they're going to manipulate
they're going to try to do propaganda
they're going to try to manipulate you
deceive you
shut down competition
by playing games human games of
different kinds
uh and sometimes even meaning well it's
not like everybody thinks they're doing
good and they're actually doing evil so
how do we prevent the worst of human
nature coming out
in a free market as well
by not giving the worst of human nature
a monopoly on violence in the
institution of governments that that
little inkling of coercion that little
bit of asymmetry
creates a gigantic like ripple effect of
asymmetry in your view yes and it ends
up just being the place where you know
corporations individuals free markets
they can't coerce without the resort to
government so you know you think about
all the examples of corrupt corporations
doing bad things
it's always
because they have certain privileges
from governments because you know that
as it exists you know coca-cola
mcdonald's all of these giant
corporations they can't do anything to
me without government they can't take
any of my money and they can't force me
to buy their stuff
and so
it doesn't matter to me you know so if
if coca-cola is corrupted that's a
problem for coca-cola customers that's a
problem for coca-cola shareholders
that's a problem for anybody who deals
with coca-cola but as somebody who
doesn't drink their stuff and isn't a
shareholder i have absolutely no
interest in what happens i they could
all go bust tomorrow and i don't care i
don't buy their product and i don't
and i'm not a shareholder so in this
situation where you choose to
voluntarily
associate with people and you only give
your money to people you want to
voluntarily give the money to so you
either buy their product or invest in
their production in that situation the
only way that a company can get my money
is if they build the product that they
uh that i value or if they convince me
that they are
going to use it in a way that's
profitable and they they might i may be
wrong you know i may invest in a company
that fails or i may invest in a company
that is turns out to be um
fraudulent but that's
my fault you know and
it's
it's my fault that i gave them my money
and then it turned out to be scoundrels
but it's a totally different problem
when we make it um
mandatory you know it's
it's violence it's um it's a crime to
put a gun to my head and force me to
subsidize companies and force me to come
at certain conclusions
you